right which makes sense because
certainly there's going to be parallels
when you talk about training individual
soldiers but when you start talking
about training teams and training
units this is where things really start
to come to light
from a leadership perspective so
importance of unit training
the army's investment in the soldier
pays off only when the unit's combat
ready
proper training develops combat ready
units by welding
skills skilled individuals into teams
and combining teams
into effective platoons companies and
combined arms forces
it is my purpose in this chapter to
highlight the application of principles
and techniques
that will contribute to improving a
unit's combat readiness in less time at
less cost
thus enabling the army to realize
full measure from its investment in the
soldier and his unit so there you go
this is about training that team getting
them to work together
theme of unit combat readiness it has
often been said
that battles are fought by squads and
platoons and
won by teamwork of small units
supported by fire
combat power is inflicted on the enemy
by fire and movement
there you go cover move welcome it's
been three it's been
three paragraphs we're talking about
cover move
this is why i start getting fired up
purpose of movement is to get the fire
in the most
advantageous position to destroy the
enemy
that's a good little thing to think
about that's why we cover and move
we cover and move to close with and
destroy the enemy to get in an
advantageous position to destroy the
enemy that's why we cover and move
one must remember however that gasoline
ammunition and other vital supplies are
needed to sustain
tactical operations accordingly emphasis
on small unit training should habitually
stress teamwork to the point that
tactical execution is accomplished with
the same precision
as dismounted drill that delivery of
effective fire is
as automatic as gun drill and that
supply to the tactical unit
is as responsive in battle as it is in
garrison
these battlefield reflections vividly
point out the basic theme of small unit
combat readiness
no small unit training should be
undertaken in a vacuum
why is he pointing this out he's
pointing this out because in the
military it's very
easy to silo yourself
it's very easy to say i want my platoon
to be good so i'm going to train my
platoon or i want my company to be good
so i'm going to train my company
or i want my battalion to be good so i'm
just going to train my battalion over
here in a vacuum
and if you're doing that you're wrong in
any organization
if you're a salesperson and you're not
training alongside the operations people
to make sure that
you know how to communicate to them what
you want and they know how to human
communicate to you what they can deliver
what about the it groups do they
understand how to handle the threshold
of emails that you're going to be
getting when you offer this new product
there's all these things that need to
you need to work
together
sometimes is it because of like internal
competition as well
like um wait that's why we wouldn't
train together
yeah maybe or or maybe
but i think it's i think it's just like
the straight up
silos you know what i'm saying just like
the straight up like hey this is my
platoon i'm gonna take care of my
platoon this is my division i'm gonna
take care of my development this is my
department i'm gonna take care of my
department
so like you're not thinking about
necessarily the other guys
or you're just like leave me alone i'm
i'm
i don't think it i think it could be
either a real like negative attitude
but it could also be just a positive
attitude that's like hey i'm going to
change my platoon
right right that's what you're focused
on yeah i'm going to train my tune i'm a
platoon commander i'm going to train my
platoon we're going to be ready yeah
yeah here's the problem you can be ready
but if you can't call for fire correctly
it doesn't matter if you've never
coordinated with a qrf before it doesn't
matter
when that qrf is needed you don't know
what you're doing
and it happens in business too hey you
know we we're we're
like i said we're the sales team we
don't care i'm not gonna i don't need to
train the
the the customer
satisfaction group i don't need to train
with them that's not my deal
right i don't care what happens when you
know once i sell the product i don't
care what happens oh really
you should care what happens because if
the client calls
customer satisfaction and looks for a
solution to a problem that they've got
as they're implementing the thing that
you just sold them and the solution
isn't there
guess what you're not getting good
reviews and you're not going to sell any
more product to that company
is the name customer satisfaction
department
is that it yeah yeah is it called that
yeah or sometimes they call it client
implementation there's many many
organizations that are set up in such a
way that there's someone that sells the
product
and then there's someone that helps them
implement the product and that's
customer satisfaction could be customer
satisfaction client satisfaction what
are some other names for it dave do you
can you think of any
customer service tech support yeah stuff
like that tech support that's a good one
tech support you might think of like
that's a broad based like hey
i've had this computer yeah for two
years
and now it's not working we're talk i'm
talking about companies where
you buy a new system of software
for your organization like a solar panel
uh i guess at home you buy a solar panel
for your roof
well let's say let's say you did that
maybe you buy solar panels for your roof
right and then great you're the salesman
you sell them to me
guess what you're done when you're done
selling me my solar panels you're on
trying to sell the next one pair
so when i call because the installation
i'm having a hard time with
i call customer satisfaction it's dave
dave picks up the phone hey i just
ordered this thing
and now he says well how many you know
and i say look we're having trouble
installing this it doesn't fit on my
roof right
and you say okay well how many panels
did you get
and what size are they and all of a
sudden he realizes that he needs to give
you feedback
that listen if the roof is this angle it
fits a different way
and so now you can sell the product
better and that will keep
people more satisfied you can also do a
follow-up call with me and say hey
hey sir i'm really sorry when i measured
your roof i thought it was this angle
and so i i told you this thing here's
what we're going to do we're actually
come out and pick up
three of the panels that you're not
going to need anymore and i'm going to
you know i'm going to give you a 10
rebate and we're also sending an
installer out there to give you a hand
and boom right now i'm taken care of
we're all happy now guess what i'm doing
when somebody asks me oh you got solar
panels
what company and i so oh echoes solar
is it a good company yeah you know it
was a little rough but they got
everything taken care of you should
definitely call them you see where i'm
going with this
yeah fully and that's weird you just
took me down the rabbit hole of
solar installation that was good maybe
not the best example but you
did good with it i'm over here to run
with it yeah yeah we're here to make it
happen what do you got but yeah because
you don't really think about that when
you're at work you know where
you you kind of want to be the best
worker and company
sure you know but the customer like
experience is kind of the whole deal you
know
you know how like man when you leave
your review you're like great product
bad customer service
and that can be like well that sucks
because i need some customer service
kind of thing so it's kind of a downer
you know yeah cause we're not thinking
everything's gonna work perfect every
single time right
not necessarily you seem saying but i'm
saying like you know you have these
elements of a
product or service that are all to the
customer it's like
it's all the same thing i'm not gonna go
to this person
just for one thing i'm gonna go i mean
as far as uh one quality of their
their product they're gonna they'll get
turned off by other departments
so if you work there for just focus on
yours bro that affects you
that's what general clark is saying you
have to interact with other people
inside your organization and if you're
not doing that you're wrong
you're wrong
fast forward a little bit training
philosophy the basic the basic
philosophy of successful training
is that of obtaining superior results
with
average personnel god i love that
well the reason we're training is to
take average people and make them
exceptional
superior results a unit to be
truly outstanding should be excellent in
all undertakings and activities
commanders must know and understand that
capab the capabilities and limitations
of personnel
and set high and exacting standards of
capabilities of the high ability of a
group
of a units personnel this tends to give
the low ability group a hopeless feeling
because of having to compete against a
standard which they cannot attain
a unit satisfactory in all things is
better than one
outstanding in some excellent in others
and unsatisfactory in a few
that's a that's a good thing to think
about
you know it's better to be good at a
bunch good at everything
than outstanding at this one thing okay
at some other things and
unsat in some final things
next section fast forward a little bit
emphasize fundamentals the basic
difference between well-trained unit and
one that is not well trained
is found in the attention paid to the
fundamentals of marksmanship
chemical biological and radiological
warfare communications maintenance
administration and all other arts and
skills that contribute to making the
unit combat ready
in the shortest possible time a
well-trained soldier is the only
foundation upon which effective combat
ready units can be built
when the soldier fails to demonstrate
proficiency and individual skills
the army's investment is wasted and the
combat readiness of the unit is
diminished
each commander should approach his
problems of combat readiness with a
sense of wartime
urgency there is no magic
formula no sweatless solution to
achieving a high state of combat
readiness in a unit
application the fundamentals enumerated
below however will help
so that by the way sweatless solution
you've heard that before right
yeah that's that's that's hack well hack
took
that actual phrase and i was i had tried
to find it in about face and of course i
about faces 836 pages and i was like oh
i know it's in here somewhere after
i've i've done it on the podcast i've
talked about the sweatless solution
there is no sweatless solution
we've covered that on the podcast you
may have wondered where he got i always
thought he made it up right
of course we thought he made it up have
you ever heard me say it maybe you
thought i made it up i didn't make it up
neither did hack
there you go i believe the source is
general clark
sweatless solution that's like that was
that
stuck with me for a long time still is
with me really because what
and part of it is yes because i had to
admit to myself bro that's me a lot of
time i'm looking for that sweat
this face it let's face it man if you
can go
and get like you know the kind where
okay
the other day echo charles going deep
standby
get some so i'm sitting on the couch
right in
big shocker there's a there's a
so the remote control i have the kind
where you know like the remote control
for the cable and then for the volume
they're two different
casuals right so i got the one for the
cable but i was like [__] the volume one
is
the volume one is somewhere else so i'm
like you know the kind you're looking
around has to be close to you
right because it's not like it's you
know in the next room or something like
this no it doesn't have
it's not going to go far it's but it's
around here somewhere right
this is what we trained for
we're talking about the solution here
so so you know you kind of look around
your little vicinity or whatever i'm not
getting up though
but i'm already sitting down that might
cause me to sweat a little bit but
whatever so i'm looking around
and i turn around and we have this ledge
like behind the couch there you know
that ledge there
and i look and it's behind me but it's
the kind
it's in this weird spot where i can't
like i gotta stand up just
if i would have stood up when i first
saw it but i would have had the remote
control enjoying some television at this
point
but i'm like trying to contort my body
like all weird
it was weird it was almost like i was
putting more effort into my sweatless
solution
then actual energy would have been
expended if i went for the
sweat solution the real one you know put
in that just stand up for a second
bro but i'm saying okay okay so the
point is
no no no no the points are easier than i
thought
the point is bro i'm talking about
hackword i'm talking about general clark
he served in world war one world war ii
korea
was a nominal decorated soldier you
couldn't get your remote
i could i could what i'm saying is
sometimes we us the people sometimes we
put so much
effort into looking for a sweatless
solution okay
so i'm saying like as a philosophy you
know and
how general clark is saying
subsequently hackword subsequently choco
well they're saying
stop looking for the sweatless solution
stop like straight up
brad just do the work stand up get the
remote control
[Music]
that's the case maybe or whatever oh
this may be that
you see what i'm saying this may be the
the apex of the echo charles
uh examples i'm just saying there's a
lot of those you know kind of like when
you're vacuuming
and you see the little thing it doesn't
want to get sucked up by the vacuum then
you like it just bend down pick it up
you should man i don't want to do that
so you'll you'll like
kick it to try to get it loose or
whatever
i'm just saying these lessons are kind
of everywhere when you think about
it
all right man general clark would agree
i think yeah know he definitely would
when he wasn't like on the line yes of
course
fighting the nazis yeah or fighting the
communists
yeah these guys didn't even have remote
controls bro they have
tvs or couches from over here just
trying to understand
all right well there you go